ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FREE [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS.
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMóN OWN.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE
OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER IS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
YES YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS MISS
REST.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN PRAYER.
LORD TODAY WE CELEBRATE YOUR
BEAUTIFUL CREATION.
THE WOMEN OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ASK YOUR BLESSING UPON
THEM.
WE HONOR OUR MOTHERS OUR SISTERS
OUR FRIENDS AND OUR WARRIORS.
THESE ARE THE WOMEN WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY HAVE PUT OTHERS BEFORE
THEMSELVES AND HAVE MADE OUR
WORLD BETTER.
THEY ARE THE WOMEN WHO WERE NOT
SATISFIED TO SIMPLY COMPLAIN.
THEY ROLLED UP THEIR SLEEVES AND
GOT TO WORK ON THE SOLUTIONS.
THEY ARE THE LEADERS AT SOMETIME
STOOD ALONE.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
THE CHAMPION FOR THE VERY
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE LEFT BEHIND
BY SO MANY.
THEY MARCHED ARM IN ARM TO
DEMAND JUSTICE.
THEY FOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OUR CHILDREN WERE PROPERLY
EDUCATED SO THEY CAN CARRY ON
THE STRUGGLE FOR INCLUSION AND
EQUITY.
FATHER YOU GIVE TO CALIFORNIA
WITH THE STRONG LOVING AND
COMMITTED WOMEN.
AND YOU GAVE THEM THE DESIRE TO
PERSIST.
AND PERSIST THEY DID.
WE PRAY NOW FOR CONTINUED
STRENGTH FOR THEM WE PRAY FOR
PROTECTION FOR THEM AND FOR
THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE FREE
WILL AND FREE THOUGHT. TO WONDER
AND QUESTION ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR GIVING US THE
DEFINITIVE ANSWER.
TO WHERE DID I COME FROM.
WE ALL CAME FROM A WOMAN.
FATHER WE DEMAND IT SO MUCH FROM
THE THOSE WERE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE AND WORK HARD.
THE Y. MIGHT PRAY FOR A LIGHTER
LOAD I KNOW THIS IS NOT WHAT
THEY SEEK.
SO TODAY ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
EVERYWHERE.
WE DO NOT ASK FOR A LIGHTER LOAD.
WE ASK FOR STRENGTH TO HAVE MORE
CAPACITY TO CONTINUE TO SERVE.
WE ASK ALL THESE THINGS IN YOUR
PRECIOUS NAME.
A MAN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASKS.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN ISSUE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
[inaudible]
ISRAEL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL THE CURSORY.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY OF EVERY TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINETEEN ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN CALDERON MOVES MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE.
NINE INTRODUCTIONS IN REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT JONES SAWYER
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR
DEATH IN THE FAMILY.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE WHEN
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KANSEN CHU.
AND THE MOM TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOANS GUESTS
WILL BE IN THE AREA OF THE
MEMBERS DESK FOR THE WOMAN OF
THE YEAR CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
ITEMS ONE AND TWO WILL BE PASSED
AND RETAINS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THREE HR FIFTEEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING THE
CLERK WILL READ HR.
FIFTEEN HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMO RELATIVE
TO WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
MISS LIMóN YOU MAY OPEN ON THE
MEASURE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I AM HONORED TO PRESENT
HR FIFTEEN PROCLAIM IN MARCH AS
WOMEN HISTORY MONTH.
WE ARE NATURAL BORN LEADERS.
WE HAVE BEEN A LONG BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE BEEN LEADERS
IN EVERY MOVEMENT OF SOCIAL
CHANGE.
WOMEN HAVE FOUGHT LONG AND HARD
THIS YEAR WE CELEBRATE A HUNDRED
YEARS SINCE THE U. S. SENATE
VOTED TO GIVE WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT WAS LATER RATIFIED.
ONE YEAR LATER IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY HOWEVER AS
RECENTLY AS THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WOMEN'S HISTORY WAS
VIRTUALLY AN UNKNOWN TOPIC.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THAT
BEGAN TO CHANGE.
AND WITH SO MANY OTHER GOOD
THINGS IT STARTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CINEMA COUNTY COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN INITIATED
THE FIRST WOMEN'S HISTORY WEEK.
THE MOVEMENT SOON WENT VIRAL
WITH PRESIDENT CARTER ISSUE IN
THE FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
PROCLAMATION DECLARING NATIONAL
WOMEN'S HISTORY WEEK.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FROM HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS EVOLVED INTO A NATION
WIDE CELEBRATION.
AGAIN I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS ALL BEGAN WITH STRONG WOMEN
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A COMMISSION THAT WAS SLOWLY
FOCUSED ON WOMEN.
THROUGHOUT THE MONTH OF MARCH WE
CELEBRATE THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF
WOMEN.
WE STRIVE TOWARDS EQUITY AND
HIGHLIGHT ALL THE WORK THAT
REMAINS TO BE DONE.
HIGHER THAN I VOTE FOR HR
FIFTEEN AND WOULD LOVE THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER MON.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR ON CASE YOU MAY SPEAK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ND
MEMBERS.
I PRIDE I PROBABLY RISE TO STAND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA R.
G. B. T. CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR
FIFTEEN WHICH PROCLAIMS MARCH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS WOMEN'S-HISTORY MONTH.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY WOMEN HAVE
MADE INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
TOWARD SHAPING THE CULTURAL MAKE
UP ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES.
AS A MEMBER OF THE LGBT CAUCUS
AND IN HONOR OF THIS SPECIAL DAY
WE ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE SOME
AMAZING LGBT WOMAN WHO I MAY
NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS IN OUR
SOCIETY.
WE SHOULD CELEBRATE THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENT THROUGH THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND ACTIVISM IN THE
FACE OF SEXISM AND ANTI LGBT
RHETORIC WE MUST CONTINUE TO
HONOR INDIVIDUALS WHY PAVE THE
WAY FOR GAY RIGHTS SUCH AS
PROMENADE L. G. B. T. WOMEN
LEADERS SUCH AS SYLVIA RIVERA.
WHO IS A QUEER LATINO WHO FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY FOR TRANSGENDER
RIGHTS TO FRIDA KAHLO WHO
HONORED INDIGENOUS MEXICAN
CULTURE THROUGH HER ART TO
JOSEPHINE BAKER WHO IS ONE OF
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL AFRICAN
AMERICAN PERFORMERS IN USED HER
PLATFORM?
AS AN ENTERTAINER TO ADVOCATE
FOR SCHOOL DESEGREGATION TO
ALICE WALKER PULITZER PRIZE
WINNER AND ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED AUTHORS AND POETS IN THE
WORLD.
I'LL TO BE TWO WOMEN HAVE BEEN
PAVING THE WAY IN ARE STILL MAKE
A RECORD NUMBER OF LGBT WOMEN
ELECTED TO OFFICE SUCH AS DâN
OCCUR ROME THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSGENDER WOMEN.
ELECTED TO SERVE I IN ANY STATE
LEGISLATURE. TWO THREE STEVE
IT'S OUR FIRST OPENLY LGBT
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMAN ELECTED TO
CONGRESS TO KRISTIN SIENNA THE
UNITED STATES SENATE'S FIRST
BISEXUAL SENATOR AND MANY OTHERS.
MOST RECENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE [inaudible]
OUR FIRST.
WOMEN TO LEAD THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE I SENATE PRESIDENT PRO
PRO TEN ARE SENATOR.
PRO TEN SPEAKER TONI ATKINS.
BRINGING ATTENTION TO THE
COUNTLESS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
HISTORICAL ROLE.
OF ALL THESE REMARKABLE WOMAN
WILL INSPIRE FUTURE GENERATIONS
TO CREATE OUR FUTURE BY WORKING
TOWARD AN EQUITABLE AND JUST
SOCIETY FRAUD.
MAY WE ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGE.
AND CELEBRATE THE LIVELIHOOD AND
ACHIEVEMENTS OF ALL THESE TRAIL.
IN OUR LGBT COMMUNITY AND TO
EACH OF THE WOMEN HERE TODAY.
MAY YOU CONTINUE TO SHARE YOUR
STORY.
MADAM SPEAKER I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON H. R..
FIFTEEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AROUND CASE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR FIFTEEN AND
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
WOMEN AND I'VE TODAY I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT DO IN THE CENTER OF
RIGHTEOUSNESS FOR CENTURIES
FOLLOWING THE JEWISH TEACHINGS
THAT JUSTICE.
MERCY AND GOODNESS ARE NOT TO BE
HELD IN A VACUUM BUT PRACTICE IN
OUR DAILY LIVES.
WE HAVE SOARED COURAGEOUSLY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF A WIDE RATE
WIDE RANGE OF PROGRESSIVE CAUSES
INCLUDING WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE LABOR
REFORM CIVIL RIGHTS SCIENTIFIC
ADVANCEMENT LITERATURE AND
HEALTH CARE.
WE CAN COUNT AMONG THE RANKS OF
JEWISH WOMEN LEADERS IN EVERY
FIELD INCLUDING GERTRUDE ELIANE
WHO DEVELOPED THE FIRST
TREATMENT FOR CHILDHOOD LEUKEMIA
AND ANTIVIRAL MEDICATION.
BELL AS BERG WHO SERVED THREE
TERMS IN CONGRESS AND ADVOCATED
FOR GROUND BREAKING BILLS
INCLUDING THE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT AND TITLE.
NINE CHOOSE JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG REMAINS ARE ARDENT
DEFENDER OF EQUAL RIGHTS AND
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE ON THE
SUPREME COURT AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND A COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE NATION.
JEWISH WOMEN HAVE NEVER STOOD
IDLY BY AGAINST OPPRESSION OR
IMMORALITY.
AS THE DAUGHTER OF A STRONG
JEWISH WOMAN WHO FOUNDED THE
FIRST CHAPTER OF NOW IN BROWARD
COUNTY FLORIDA AND FORCED ME TO
GO DOOR TO DOOR WITH HER.
AS SHE ADVOCATED FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS IN FLORIDA WHEN I WAS A
GIRL AND IS A PROUD JEWISH WOMAN
MYSELF BY URGENT AYE VOTE ON HR
FIFTEEN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR.
FIFTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS WE ARE HONORED TO
CELEBRATE WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
AND THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR.
THIS MONTH GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON AND TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE MADE ALL OF OUR
LIVES POSSIBLE.
AND STRONGER AND RICHER.
ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK CAUCUS I
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT FOR FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN ON THE ON THE SHORES.
AND SO THIS IS THE FOUR
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY SIXTEEN
NINETEEN OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THE CARD AND
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN.
THIS PAST WEEKEND WE CELEBRATED
TO THE FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
CELEBRATION IN SAN DIEGO. TO
RECOGNIZE HOW FAR WE HAVE COME
AS AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN AND
YET HOW FAR WE NEED TO GO.
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN WELL WE
CELEBRATE OUR HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
HAS BEEN ONE OF PAYING
[inaudible]
SCORN.
SOMETIMES FRUSTRATION AND
DISCUSS.
AND PERSECUTION.
AND YET IN SPITE OF ALL OF THAT
IT IS ALSO A HISTORY OF VICTORY.
A HISTORY OF OVERCOMING
TREMENDOUS ODDS AND PUSHING THE
A GENERATION AND GENERATIONS.
FOR IT WAS SO JOURNAL TRUE TO
ASK THE CRITICAL QUESTION ON
BEHALF OF ALL AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN WHO SUFFER IN THIS COUNTRY.
A NOT A WOMAN.
A QUESTION THAT WAS OFTENTIMES
MISUNDERSTOOD.
BUT ONE THAT CONSTANTLY REMINDED
US THAT DESPITE WHATEVER
BENEFITS MAY EXIST FOR WHITE
WOMEN IN THIS NATION.
THE ATTITUDE WAS NOT THE SAME
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN.
AND SO THEY WERE EXPECTED TO
BASICALLY CARRY THE LOAD MOST
MEN CARRY THAT WOMEN DIDN'T HAVE
TO KERRY.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO DO THAT
EVEN TO THIS DAY.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF HOLDING UP
A NATION AND A WORLD AND THE SKY
WITH THEMSELVES.
MARGARET WALKER TALKS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
A COFFIN SEEN AS THE MULES OF
THE WORLD.
BECAUSE THEY CARRY THE BURDEN
THAT NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO CARRY.
KAREN ROGERS CALLS A STURDY
BLACK BRIDGES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE PLACES SO
MANY HAVE CROSSED OVER ON IT
HAVE MADE POSSIBLE FOR US TO
GROW AND TO DEVELOP.
I AM HONORED TO REPRESENT THE
MILLIONS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHO CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
GREAT DIGNITY?
AND DESPITE THE SCORE THAT THEY
MAY HAVE FELT HISTORICALLY.
THEY CONTINUE TO LIFT UP
THEMSELVES WITH THEIR CHILDREN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND ALSO THE REST OF THE WORLD
SO WE'RE ON A TODAY TO CELEBRATE
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN ALONG
WITH ALL OF THE WOMEN WHO MAKE
US ALL POSSIBLE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I BOTH THE
H. R..
FIFTEEN THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MR COLOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
FIFTEEN TO COMMEMORATE WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WHICH IS.
CERTAINLY DISTINCT PLEASURE
GIVEN THE FACT THAT.
ONE OF THE GREAT --
EXPERIENCES OF SERVING ON THIS
FLOOR ARE THE INCREDIBLE WOMEN
THAT WE GET TO SERVE WITH.
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR COURAGEOUS
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF SOCIAL MOVEMENTS.
THAT HAVE SHAPED OUR SOCIETY
TODAY. ONE SUCH PIONEER INCLUDES
CONGRESS AMER PATSY MINK.
AS A JAPANESE AMERICAN WOMAN SHE
MADE HISTORY.
AS THE FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR TO
SERVE IN CONGRESS IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE SHOT A
LANDMARK GENDER EQUITY
LEGISLATION INCLUDING THE TITLE
NINE AMENDMENT TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT.
WHICH PROHIBITED JET GENDER
DISCRIMINATION THE TWO SHINS
MAKING IT VERY CLEAR EARLY ON
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE
REPRESENTATION --
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
A YEAR LATER IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX MARCH FONG YOU BECAME THE
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
AFTER SERVING FOUR TERMS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SHE WAS ELECTED AS A
SECRETARY OF STATE THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN EVER.
ELECTED TO A STATE COSTUMES TO A
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE IN THE
UNITED STATES --
AND OF COURSE.
WE WILL HAVE --
FOR BUT EVEN.
IN OUR OWN STATE OF MORE COURT
MORE --
CURRENTLY WITH CONGRESS
EMERGENCY CHIU AND CENTER CALMLY
HARRIS.
AND OF COURSE --
SURE ON A MOCK. FOR BETTY --
HAVE THAT OF REALLY MADE US
PROUD AS CALIFORNIANS TO BE ON
THE FOREFRONT OF ASIAN MAKE
REPRESENTATION AND NATIONALLY
WITH PREMIER DIAPAUSE STEPHANIE
MURPHY IN CONGRESS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO SEE DIVERSITY.
IN ALL ITS STRIPES OF WITHIN
WOMEN LEADERS THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION.
IT'S AMAZING TO LOOK AROUND AND
SEE THE WOMEN THAT SURROUND US
TODAY AND THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY THE REPRESENTS.
CALIFORNIA AND ESPECIALLY
GRATIFYING ON BEHALF A PAT
LEGISLATIVE CAUGHT TO SEE SO
MANY A. P. I. LEADERS THAT ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY AND WE WANT
TO CERTAINLY CONGRATULATE.
ALL OF YOU THEY AND SO MANY
OTHERS HAVE SHATTERED GLASS
CEILINGS AND ABOUT PUSH OUR
STATE AND NATION TOWARDS
EQUALITY FOR WOMEN AND A MORE
JUST FUTURE FOR ALL PLEASE JOIN
ME IN VOTING AYE. FOR H. I..
FIFTEEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU.
AND I'M PROUD TO STAND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF HR FIFTEEN
HISTORICALLY IN CALIFORNIA OUR
MOTHERS IN OUR GRANDMOTHERS AS
LATINOS TOOK CARE OF YOUR KIDS.
WEEK CLEAN YOUR HOTEL ROOMS WE
CLEAN YOUR HOUSES WE PICTURE
FOOD.
AND TODAY ALTHOUGH WE RISEN AND
RANKS TO DOCTORS AND LAWYERS
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND JUDGES.
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS WE STILL
FACE THE REALITY THAT LATINOS IN
PARTICULAR IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE
LOWEST PAID WORKERS IN THE
NATION.
WE EARN ON AVERAGE FORTY FOUR
CENTS OF THE DOLLAR OF OUR WHITE
MALE COUNTERPARTS.
THAT PUTS US AT THE BOTTOM WE
ARE THE ONLY DEMOGRAPHIC TO
NEVER HOLD A STATEWIDE POSITION
IN CALIFORNIA DESPITE BEING 20%
OF THE POPULATION.
IT'S IN HEARTENING TO LOOK
AROUND THIS ROOM AND SEE SO MANY
WOMEN BEING HONORED HERE TODAY
WHO ARE LEVINE AS BUT WE KNOW WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
AND A LOT OF RESPECT TO DEMAND.
WITH THAT THOUGH WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR SISTERS WHO ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND ASIAN
AMERICAN.
AND CAUCASIAN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN VERY BIG BEING
RECOGNIZED HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE
KNOW TOGETHER WE ARE STRONGER.
AND THAT AS WE RISE AND THAT
BOTH RISES THAT WE WILL ALL RISE
TOGETHER AND WE KNOW THAT YOU'LL
REACH BEHIND AND PULL US UP AS
WELL.
SO ON BEHALF OF LATINO CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON HR.
FIFTEEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALES.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM IS LIMON YOU
MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO A
VOTE ON THIS MEMBER ON THIS
MEASURE THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR FIFTEEN THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR.
FIFTEEN THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SEVENTY EIGHT CO
AUTHORS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND BEFORE I RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE MONN AGAIN TO OPEN
OUR CEREMONY I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE HAVE --
ONE OF OUR STATE LEADERS IN THE
CHAMBER HERE TODAY STATE
TREASURER FOUND AMMAN FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE SO WE WANT
TO WELCOME HER TO CHAMBERS.
SHE GOT THERE THE LAST.
THIS LIMON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR OPENING.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS TODAY WE TAKE A BREAK
FROM OUR USUAL BUSINESS TO
CELEBRATE SOME REMARKABLE
CALIFORNIANS IN RECOGNITION OF
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATORS
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IT'S A PLEASURE
AND AN HONOR TO BE SURROUNDED BY
SO MANY WOMEN LEADERS WHO ARE
STRONG BULL.
EACH OF OUR WOMEN OF THE YEAR
HONOREES ARE WONDERFUL EXAMPLES
OF WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA GOLDEN.
TO OUR HONOREES.
YOU PERSON YOU PERSONIFY THE
SPIRIT OF OUR GREAT STATE.
EACH OF YOU HAS MADE UNIQUE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE LIVES OF
YOUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS.
YOU HAVE BLAZE TRAILS.
YOU HAVE SWORN TO HEAL.
YOU HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
IMPROVE OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU HAVE BEEN AT THE FRONTLINE
IN THE BATTLE FOR EQUAL RIGHTS.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN YOUR TRUTH AND
DE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
YOU'VE BROKEN BARRIERS AND
SERVED AS AN INSPIRATION FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
AND AS STRONG WOMEN.
ALONG WITH THE HONOR BESTOWED
UPON YOU TODAY I HOPE YOU WILL
ALSO ACCEPT THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT COMES WITH IT.
THE NEED FOR STRONG WOMEN DOES
NOT END WITH US IN THE ROOM
TODAY IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO HOLD THE DOOR OPEN FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WOMEN LEADERS.
WE NEED YOU TO HELP CULTIVATE
OUR FUTURE.
WE MUST ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN TO
LEAD AND WE MUST SUPPORT THEM IN
THEIR EFFORTS.
WHEN WOMEN LEAD WE ADDRESS
TOPICS LIKE?
PAY PARITY AND POVERTY.
CHILD CARE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
WOMEN'S IN SAFETY HEALTH
EDUCATION.
BANKING TAX AND REV.
AGRICULTURE AND SO MANY ISSUES.
WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF GREAT WOMEN
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AND FROM
THOSE IN THE ROOM TODAY.
CONTINUE TO BE THE FOUNDATION OF
WHAT WE OF WHAT WE USE TO BUILD
OTHER WOMEN MOVING FORWARD.
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND EVERYBODY
WITHIN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
CHAMBERS.
I THINK YOU FOR DEDICATING YOUR
LIVES TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
IN GREAT AND SMALL WE AREALL
INDEBTED TO YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MEMBERS ON
A REASON GAS WE WILL NOW BEGIN
THE SPECIAL CEREMONY TO HONOR
THE WOMEN OF THE YEAR.
IN KEEPING WITH OUR PREVIOUS
PRACTICES WITH REGARD TO THE
CEREMONY THE NAME OF THE
HONOREES WILL BE READ AND
DISTRICT ORDER.
AT THIS TIME MISTER TING AND
MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT DISTRICTS
ONE PRETEND SHOULD RETIRE TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON.
WOMEN'S LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS VICE
CHAIR MONIQUE LIMON REPUBLICAN
LEADER MARIE WALDRON WILL
PRESENT THE HONOREES WITH A
SPECIALLY PREPARED CERTIFICATE.
AFTER THEY ARE ESCORTED BY THEIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I ASKED SPEAKER RENDON
CHAIRWOMAN LIMONIUM LEADER
WALDRON TO COME JOIN US AT THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBER.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE NAMES OF
THE HONOREES.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINETEEN
DOCTOR NADINE BURKE HERIS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM.
DOCTOR NADINE BURKE HARRIS IS AN
AWARD WINNING PHYSICIAN
RESEARCHER AN ADVOCATE DEDICATED
CHANGING THE WAY OUR SOCIETY
RESPONSE TO ONE OF THE MOST
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES OF
OUR TIME.
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SHE WAS
APPOINTED AS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
EVER SURGEON GENERAL BY GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ONE
ROBERTA BOBBY SWANSON ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY ROBERTA
BOBBY SWANSON HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
VOLUNTEER AND NONPROFIT DIRECTOR
IN ABOUT A COUNTY SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE HER LEGACY
OF PUBLIC SERVICE HAS BEEN THAT
SERVING POPULATIONS IN NEED FROM
ADULTS TO CHILDREN.
AND ALWAYS FOR THE GREATER GOOD
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR HER YEARS OF
DEDICATED SERVICE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TO
NATALIE ARROYO ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
NARROWLY ARROYO DISTRICT TO
WOMAN OF THE YEAR LIVES AND
WORKS IN EUREKA AND SERVES ON
THE U. BECAUSE CITY COUNCIL.
A SENIOR PLANNER WITH REDWOOD
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY NATALIE
IS ANALYST AND MEMBER OF THE U.
S. COAST GUARD RESERVE.
NATALIE ALSO CURRENTLY SERVES ON
THE BOARD OF THE HUMBLE TROLL
COUNCIL
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THREE
TERRY DEVOS ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER.
JERRY DO BOTH AS A SACRAMENTO
VALLEY NATIVE IN EVERY SENSE OF
THE WORD.
THROUGH HER WORK AS A FARMER
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER JERRY HAS DEMONSTRATED HER
STRENGTH AND INSPIRING
COMMITMENTS OUR COMMUNITY.
MOST RECENTLY TERRY WAS ASSIGNED
TO THE CAMPFIRE WHERE SHE SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS AS A VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTER.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE CAMPFIRE
TERRY BEGAN TO ORGANIZE DINNERS
TO SHOW APPRECIATION FOR THOSE
WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
AND THE FIRE.
TERRY BUT LOCAL USINESSES
TOGETHER WITH CASH AND IN KIND
DONATIONS AND RAISED OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FOR UBER AND ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF TEXAN.
ME FOR AN HAS INFLUENCED OUR
COMMUNITY THROUGH MUSIC THEATER
PUBLIC SIR AN ACTIVE SUPPORTER
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION.
HE SERVED AS MAYOR OF DIXON IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WAS DIXON
CITIZEN OF THE YEAR IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE AND DIXON'S
OUTSTANDING SENIOR CITIZEN IN
.
TWENTY ELEVEN FROM A STAND SOON
OF THE CELL ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S ALL REPRESENTS
THE BEST SUPERS ORIEL DISTRICT
AT ALL DORADO COUNTY.
SEE WAS ELECTED TO THE EL DORADO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN A FORTY YEAR
RESIDENTS OF LAKE TAHOE COS BUT
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS IN PUBLIC
SERVICE DEDICATED TO LAKE TAHOE
COMMUNITY AND ENVIRONMENT
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIX CHRIS
WHY IT IS SCORED BY FAMILY
MEMBER KILEY.
CHRIS WHITE SERVED AT WESTERN
POTS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS AS A TEACHER
AND COUNSELOR.
IN TWENTY TEN CHRIS WAS ELECTED
TO THE W. P. U. S. D. BOARD OF
TRUSTEES FOR SHE SERVES
CURRENTLY LAST YEAR CHRIS
COORDINATED THE LINCOLN
COMMITTEE THANKSGIVING DINNER
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS AND OVER
THREE HUNDRED VICTIMS OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE
PARADISE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVEN
WITH YOUR ALARM ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
THIS YEAR ALONG AS A SYMBOL OF
RESOLVE FOR REFUGEE WOMEN IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA AFTER FLEEING
HER HOME COUNTRY OF AFGHANISTAN
AND SURVIVING DOMESTIC ABUSE.
THIS YEAR IS NOW AN AMERICORPS
MEMBER AND WORKS AT THE YELLOW
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER TO
REVITALIZE PLANTS REFUGEE WOMEN
COPING WITH EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHT
PASS A SCORE BASED ON THE NUMBER
COOLEY.
MICHELE K. HOUSES SERVED IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FIELD
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
RANGING FROM A LOCAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AGENCY IN CHILD WELFARE
ISSUES. TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S VICTIM WITNESS
PROGRAM AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES SHE MADE THE PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
INVOLVED IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM
[inaudible]
FROM ASSEMBLY KATHERINE K. ALL
THE ANI ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBER COOPER.
KATHERINE K. ALL THE ANI IS ON
THE ELK GROVE REGIONAL
SCHOLARSHIP BOARD AND IS A
RETIRED MEMBER OF THE LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT BOARD
OF TRUSTEES. FOR SHE SERVED FOR
OVER TWO DECADES INCLUDING TWO
STINTS IN THE ROLE OF PRESIDENT
OF THE BOARD
[inaudible]
FROM AS THE COURT ROOM WHILE
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
THE GIRL TAKES GREAT PRIDE IN
HER ROLE AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF WEST FOR IN COMMUNITY
SERVICES WHERE SHE'S ABLE TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY SHE'S LIVED
IN FOR MANY YEARS SHE'S GRATEFUL
TO ALL THOSE IN WEST MARIN WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED HER AND HELP HER
SHAPE.
WHO SHE IS TODAY
?
FROM A SOME JENNY CAN KNOW WHERE
IT'S GOING TO BUY SOMETHING
MEMBER FLORA.
COUNCILMEMBER JENNY CAN WHERE IS
A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF MODESTO
RETIRED AFTER FORTY EIGHT YEARS
AS A REGISTERED NURSE.
SHE HAS FIVE CHILDREN AND EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN SHE HAS BEEN
ACTIVE IN SEVERAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
STANISLAUS COUNTY COMMISSION ON
AGING.
SENIOR ELDER ABUSE PREVENTION
ALLIANCE AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY AND THE LAZARUS
MINISTRY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTEEN
JULIA ANDERSON CHART ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
GILLIAN ANDERSON SHIRTS LIFE
CHANGING EVENT CAME JANUARY
SEVENTEENTH.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE SHE WAS
TEACHING SECOND GRADE AT
CLEVELAND ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
STOCKTON WHEN A GUNMAN KILLED
FIVE CHILDREN AND WE DID THIRTY
OTHER STUDENTS AND A TEACHER.
WITH OTHER TEACHERS AND SHE
DOUBTED CLEVELAND SCHOOL
REMEMBERS A LOCAL ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
MISSY ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
MITZI SANCHEZ IS A LIFELONG
VALLEJO RESIDENT AND TIRELESS
ADVOCATE FOR MISSING CHILDREN IN
CHILD SAFETY.
AS A SURVIVOR OF CHILD ABDUCTION
HERSELF IT'S HE HAS SHOWN
INCREDIBLE STRENGTH BY ASSISTING
FAMILIES AFFECTED BY OBJECTION
AND USING HER PERSONAL STORY TO
EDUCATE OTHERS ON OBJECTION
PREVENTION THROUGH THAT HER
NONPROFIT FOUNDATION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTEEN
FOR WHEN NOT TERMINATING
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS DR ELENA TELL MEANING
CURRENTLY SERVES AS PRESIDENT OF
BERKELEY CITY COLLEGE.
DR TERMINATING AS A FIRST
GENERATION FILIPINO AMERICAN A
PRODUCT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
AND A SELF DESCRIBED ACTIVIST
SCHOLAR.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER DR TOM
INNING HAS ADVOCATED FOR AN
OVERSEEING INITIATIVE THAT
FOSTER EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
PREPARING STUDENTS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS FOR PROFESSIONAL AND
PERSONAL SUCCESS
.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN DOCTOR
TAMMY WING Là ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBERS BAUER-KAHAN.
DOCTOR TAMMY Mà IS MAKING GIANT
STRIDES A GROUNDBREAKING
SCIENTIFIC ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WORKING AS AN EXPERIMENTAL
PLASMA PHYSICIST AT THE NATIONAL
IGNITION FACILITY AT THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL
LABORATORY.
THE FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN
SHE IS STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
EDUCATION AND MENTORING AND
ENCOURAGING YOUNG STUDENTS TO
SHARE HER PASSION FOR SCIENCE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTEEN
READER ARE SOME L. ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
WE ARE SOME L. AS THE FOUNDER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO INTERFAITH
COUNCIL IN THE UNITED RELIGIONS
INITIATIVE.
CO FOUNDER OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
WINTER HOMELESS SHELTER SYSTEM
AND A LIFETIME ACTIVISTS FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS CIVIL RIGHTS
INTERFACE RELATIONS AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTEEN
VICTORIA CALL CASKEY ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER BONTA.
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE RHETORICAL AKOWSKI AS THE
FIRST OPENLY TRANSGENDER TRIAL
JUDGE IN THE UNITED STATES.
JUDGE COLE CASKEY HAS SERVED IN
BOTH CIVIL AND CRIMINAL TRIAL
ASSIGNMENTS SHE'S PASSIONATE
ABOUT INSURING EXPANDING ACCESS
TO JUSTICE PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE WITH LIMITED RESOURCES AND
HAS BEEN A LEADER IN EDUCATING
THE JUDICIARY ON TRANSGENDER
ISSUES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
ASIA WHAT HA ESCORTED BY SOME
THE MEMBER COURT.
MISS I ISSUE ONE HA A FORMER
FOSTER CHILD RECENTLY BECAME ONE
OF ONLY TWO AFGHAN AMERICAN
WOMEN TO SERVE IN PUBLIC OFFICE
IN THE UNITED STATES. ONE OF
ASIA'S MAIN BELIEVES IS TO KEEP
ONE EYE ON THE PAST AND WHEN I
ON THE FUTURE AS SHE CONTINUES
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
ONE VERA VERIFIED YOU ARE
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER GRAY.
MIRA RIVERA ACCU ARE WAS BORN IN
THE CITY OF QUALITY MOLD TO
ALLAH SHE IS DEGREE IN
AGRICULTURE BUSINESS FROM FRESNO
STATE AND LIVES IN WENT IN WITH
THEIR SPOUSE IT ALTHOUGH AND HER
CHILDREN ABRAHAM ERIN AN AREA --
SHE SUPPORTS OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH A VARIETY OF VOLUNTEER
EFFORTS INCLUDING AS PRESIDENT
OF THE WAY OF A LATINO ROTARY
CLUB OF WINTON
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
TWO REVEREND DR G. PENNY NIXON
ESCORTED BY SOMETHING NUMBER
MULLIN.
REVEREND DR G. PENNY NIXON IS
THE SENIOR MINISTER OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL CHURCH OF SAN
MATTEO UNITED CHURCH OF CHRIST
AND THE CONVENER OF THE
PENINSULA SOLIDARITY NETWORK.
SHE'S A SOCIAL ACTIVIST FOR ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY LGBT RIGHTS AND
IMMIGRATION.
HEADING RECEIVE THIS RECOGNITION
FOR THE WOMAN ON THE FRONT LINES
OF JUSTICE ISSUES
DISTRICT
TWENTY THREE WITH ME BANKER
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
WHEN THE BUNKER IS A FORMER
SOCIAL WORKER AND ADOPTIVE
MOTHER?
TOGETHER WITH HER HUSBAND DANIEL
WITH THE LOT CITY WITHOUT WORK
IN A NON PROFIT THAT WORKS
COLLECTIVELY WITH GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUAL
FAMILIES TO CHANGE THE LIVES OF
ON ALL CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
FIVE BRENDA J. HE WON ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
BRENDA WONG REGULARLY VOLUNTEERS
AT THE BERRYESSA CHINESE SCHOOL
THE CHINESE HISTORICAL AND
CULTURAL PROJECT AND THE ST
ELIZABETH CHURCH.
AS A LIFELONG VOLUNTEER SHE'S
PASSIONATE ABOUT HELPING YOUNG
PEOPLE GROW AND GET BACK TO
THEIR HOME SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
SIX SAN.
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER MATHIS.
SANTEE CELLS HAS BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THE TO NEW BUT CHAMBER
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO SERVING AS A
BOARD MEMBER COMMITTEE CHAIR
TREASURE AND IN NEW BUT
MAINSTREET CHAIR.
AFTER YEARS OF VOLUNTEERING SHE
WAS HIRED AS THE C. E. O. OF THE
TWO NEW WHICH CHAMBER AND
GENERATE.
TWENTY TEN SANTEE GRADUATED FROM
THE WESTERN AREA CHAMBER EXACT
IF YOU HAVE ANY AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AN ATTENTIVE WAYS AN
AMERICAN CONFERENCE OF CHAMBER
EXECUTIVES CONFERENCES.
AND WEBINARS TO CONTINUE TO
LEARN HOW TO IMPROVE HER CHAMBER.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT --
TWENTY SEVEN LINDA RAE IS
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA.
I WANT TO ASK REYES WAS BORN IN
THE PHILIPPINES AND MIGRATED TO
THE UNITED STATES IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE SHE HAS
SERVED IN MANY LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS AND IS AN ACTIVE
COMMISSIONER WITH THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA.
IN ADDITION TO OUR COMMUNITY
ACTIVISM SHE MENTORS NURSING
STUDENT AT THE NURSE BUILDERS
ACADEMY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
EIGHT AMERICA POLICY AND
ESCORTED BY SOME REMEMBER LOW.
DOCTOR MERRY A POLICY AND JOIN
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AT THE
THIRTY EIGHTH PRESIDENT ON JULY
FIRST.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEADER OF THE
FOUNDING CAMPUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WITH
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
BOSNIAN IS COMMITTED TO STUDENT
SUCCESS OPEN AND INCLUSIVE
LEADERSHIP FOSTERING A CULTURE
OF CURIOSITY IN DISCOVERY
BUILDING IN DURING CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
NINE AM LOPEZ ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS DOWN.
DOCTOR AND LOPEZ AS A PROFESSOR
EMERITA AN AUTHOR OF THE
FARMWORKERS JOURNEY A MOVING
ACCOUNT OF THE EXPERIENCES OF
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS TRAVELING
FROM MEXICO TO CALIFORNIA.
SHE FOUNDED THE CENTER FOR
FARMWORKERS FAMILIES
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER CONDITIONS FOR FARMWORKER
FAMILIES IN BOTH MEXICO AND THE
UNITED STATES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
ADELIA MORALIS RASO ESCORTED
FAMILY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS DALY
MORALIS RUSSELL EMIGRATED TO
CALIFORNIA IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT INTEL ROY
SHE ENJOYED A THIRTY YEAR
TEACHING CAREER EARNED A
MASTER'S IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AND WAS NAMED TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LATINO PHILANTHROPIST
OF THE YEAR.
ADELIA IS DEVOTED TO YOUR FAMILY
AND AS A SPOKESPERSON FOR
BUSINESS YOU CO BAND WITH HER
HUSBAND
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
ONE NOW MISTY HER ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
MISTY HER AS AN EDUCATIONAL
LEADER AND ROLE MODEL IN THE
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BEFORE RISING TO HER CURRENT
POSITION AS AN INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE STATE'S
FOURTH LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MISSY WAS THE FIRST NAME OF
PRINCIPLE OF LONG DESCENT IN THE
UNITED STATES AT FRESNO UNIFIED
MISTY LEADING OVERSEAS THE
DISTRICTS IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS
AND A NUMBER OF AREAS.
SUCH AS IMPLEMENTING CURRICULUM
STAFF DEVELOPED
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY TO
PAT NOLAN ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS PAT KNOWN AS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO
SERVE AS VICE MAYOR OF CORCORAN.
SHE IS CHAIRPERSON OF KINGS
COMMITTEE ACTION BOARD AND
MANAGES THE FIRST UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH IS FOOD FATE.
SHE WAS PREVIOUSLY NAMED
CORCORAN'S WOMAN OF THE YEAR AND
HANDS ACROSS THE VALLEY'S
VOLUNTEER OF THE YEAR
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
THREE ELANOR RIVERA ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
ELENA RIVERA WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN BARSTOW CALIFORNIA BILLION IS
CURRENTLY THE ADMINISTRATOR AND
DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT FOR
GREATER HOPE FOUNDATION.
A LOCAL FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY AND
ADOPTION SERVICE HE'S ALSO THE
INSTRUCTIONAL SPECIALIST UP ARE
STILL COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AS WELL AS CHAIRPERSON OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
BARSTOW AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CHOOSE RECENTLY PRESIDENT OF
ROTARY CLUB OF ARE STILL AS WELL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
FOUR JENNIFER JANSON ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER FONG.
JENNIFER JOHNSON IS THE FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GLOBAL
FAMILY KERR NETWORK. FOR WORK
AIMS TO PREVENT AND SPREAD THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROVIDE
REHABILITATIVE CARE TO VICTIMS
OF COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND IMPLEMENT
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS TO
ISSUES AROUND CHILD PROTECTION --
AND NOT ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT.
JENNIFER AND HER TEAM WORK
WORLDWIDE IN THE UNITED STATES
CANADA INDIA NEPAL MYANMAR SRI
LANKA THAILAND EL SALVADOR IN
FRANCE TELL CHILDREN IN NEED OF
LOVING FAMILY CARE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
FIVE DANIEL RALLY ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
DANIEL RALLY IS AN ANTI HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ACTIVISTS ORDINATOR
AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO IS
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INSTITUTE.
IN ADDITION TO WORKING WITH
CENTRAL COAST NONPROFITS TO
FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING DANIELLE
THE IT'S THE INSTITUTE'S EFFORTS
TO TRAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
RECOGNIZE AND HELP TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX GRAND MARQUIS ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER LACKEY.
FRAN IS A LEADER IN THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPROVING ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION TO LOCAL YOU.
FRANCE MISSION IS TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT OF LATINO STUDENTS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN FRANK CREATED IT THE
CHASING YOUR DREAMS SCHOLARSHIP.
WARNING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
STUDENTS WITH SCHOLARSHIP
TOTALING OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
EIGHT MELANIE HECK AND ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH.
MILLING CHECK IN IS A PRODUCT OF
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE THIRTY
EIGHTH DISTRICT HER LOVE OF
READING AND WRITING COMPELLED
HER TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
JOURNALISM.
PERMISSION HAS LED TO AN AWARD
WINNING PUBLICATION HER FIRST CO
AUTHORED BY.
A DEAL WITH THE DOUBLE WHICH
DETAILS EFFORTS TO UNMASK A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CASE OF
CONSUMER FRAUD THATPREYED ON
ELDERLY VICTIMS FOR DECADES.
SHE IS A PROUD MOM AND CURRENTLY
LIVES IN SANTA CLARITA WITH HER
HUSBAND RYAN AND ONE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER RORY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
NINE CYNTHIA A SOUR ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING NUMBER THREE OF US.
CYNTHIA SOUR AS A MOTHER
PASSIONATE COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
AND LIFELONG SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
RESIDENT SHE'S THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SUN VALLEY AREA NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL.
WHICH HE LEADS CONVERSATIONS
WITH GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS ON ISSUES
AFFECTING QUALITY OF LIFE
DEVELOPMENT AND BUSINESS AMONG
MANY MOTHERS.
UNAPOLOGETIC IN HER PURSUIT TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND NEEDS IS A
AUDITIONING FOR ONE OF THE YEAR
FOR THE SIMPLY DISTRICT
.
THIRTY NINE FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FORTY CHRISTINE THE
SCOTT ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
ON THIS.
CHRISTINE SCOTT IS A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR SO CAL GAS
AND COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY
OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA DISTRICT. TO
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS
CHRISTINE HAS WORKED WITH
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BENEFITTED
THE REGION.
ALMOST TEN OF THOSE YEARS HAVE
BEEN SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING OUR WAY OF LIFE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
CHRISTINE HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
TO BRING ABOUT POSITIVE OUTCOMES
IN AREAS SUCH AS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION AND SAFETY
ESPECIALLY IN RANCHO CUCAMONGA
WHICH IS MADE HER HOME AND IS
PASSIONATELY COMMITTED TO BE A
PART OF FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FORTY ONE FLOOR THE FARBER.
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN.
MS BARBER SERVES AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE TOURNAMENT OF
ROSES FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR. TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP FOR THE ROSE PARADE
AND THE ROSE BOWL GAME NEXT
JANUARY.
AS THE FIRST LATINA AND THIRD
WOMAN TO SERVE IN THIS POSITION
MISS FARBER WILL OFFER AN
IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVE AND
APPROACH.
PROFESSIONALLY SHE'S AN
ACCOMPLICE TRIAL LAWYER AT HAN
HAN ELLO P. IN THE AREA OF
EMPLOYMENT LITIGATION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
THREE TO RESET TERRY WALKER
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
TERRY WALKER IS THE MAYOR OF THE
CAN YADA FLINT RIDGE.
SHE'S BEEN AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE FROM HER
DECADES WITH THE LOOKING OUT OF
FLINTRIDGE GUILD OF HUNTINGTON
MEMORIAL HOSPITAL TWO OR THREE
TERMS AS PRESIDENT OF THE LOCAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
MERE WALKER HAS BEEN A TIRELESS
VOLUNTEER AND COMMUNITY LEADER
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
FOUR MONIQUE MARIE GARCIA
ESCORTED BY SONY MEMBER IRWIN.
MONIQUE GARCIA IS A UNIT
DIRECTOR AT THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB OF GREATER OXNARD.
AND PORT HUENEME ME SHE'S AN
ACTIVE VOLUNTEER FOR MANY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND A
MEMBER OF THE COUNTY OF VENTURA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ADVISORY BOARD
AND A MEMBER OF THE TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH COMMITTEE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
FIVE MICHELLE FUENTES MARANDA
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
MICHELLE POINT IS MARANDA AS
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF THE
LINES FOR COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT.
THIS FIGHT IS MARANDA HAS
DEDICATED HERSELF TO ADVOCTING
FOR UNDERSERVED YOUTH IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY SHE'S ALSO
PRESENT AT THE CANOGA PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL FOR SHE
ADVOCATES FOR AND BRINGS
AWARENESS TO INVESTING IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY SIX
STEPHANIE CLASSY GAMER IT'S
GOING TO BUY SOMETHING SAYS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
SEVEN GWENDOLYN LORRAINE DOWDY
ROGERS ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
REYES.
WHEN THE WHEN THE RAIN DALY
ROGERS IS A COMMUNITY LEADER A
SCHOOL BOARD VICE PRESIDENT?
AND AUTHOR AN ADVOCATE AND
MENTOR FOR YOUNG WOMEN.
AN ASSISTANT PASTOR AND NOTED
SPEAKER SHE IS ALSO THE FOUNDER
OF YOUNG WOMEN'S EMPOWERMENT
FOUNDATION WHICH EMPOWERS YOUNG
WOMEN TO REACH THEIR HIGHEST
ASPIRATIONS BE A MENTORING AND
SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR ANA
ESTEVEZ SCORED BY SOME REMEMBER
RUBIO.
ANA ESTEVEZ IS BORN IN SCRANTON
PENNSYLVANIA AND REYES
INVOLVEMENT FOR CALIFORNIA ON
APRIL TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND S. AND P. HE WAS
MURDERED BY HER EX HUSBAND.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
AND IT HAS BEEN A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR CHILD SAFETY AND
FAMILY COURT REFORM BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BARBARA
MESSINA ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHILD.
BARBACENA SUCCESSFULLY SERVE
THIRTY TWO YEARS AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL EIGHT YEARS ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND TWENTY FOUR ON
THE ALL HAMBRE CITY COUNCIL.
SHE IS CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE YMCA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND CONTINUES TO STAY
INVOLVED IN HER COMMUNITY.
HER FAMILY IS HER GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
KATHY GRIFFIN ESCORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER BLOOM. TWO TIME EMMY A
GRAMMY AWARD WINNING COMMITTEE
AND FORMER WRITER AND PRODUCER.
KATHY GRIFFIN COMBINES ARE
UNIVERSALLY RECOGNIZED BRAND OF
PULL NO PUNCHES COMEDY WHETHER
PASSIONATE ADVOCACY FOR WOMEN
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND OTHER
DISENFRANCHISED GROUPS TO SHARE
HER EMPOWERING MESSAGES THE
QUALITY TO ACTIVISM AND HUMOR TO
SOLD OUT AUDIENCES AROUND THE
WORLD
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
THREE C. L. LOPEZ.
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
CARILLO.
RESEAL LOPEZ AS A RESTAURANT
HERE FOR THE MONTH TO SEE --
HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FIFTY ONE BORN AND RAISED IN THE
LAW WHAT HAKA WE SEE IT AS A
PARTNER AT WELL LOOK WHAT.
WELL HOP IN RESTAUANT FOUNDED
BY HER FATHER AND INFLUENTIAL
FIGURE IN THE DUST ON MAKE A
CULTURE OF LOS ANGELES.
RESITA IS AN INSPIRATIONAL
LEADER AND COUNTLESS PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
ARE BOUNDLESS COMPASSION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY TWO
SAN FRANCISCO.
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ CENTERS THESE GO
OVERSEE THE DAILY OPERATIONS OF
THE INTAKE CENTER A FACILITY
THAT PROVIDES SHORT TERM
INTENSIVE TECHNICAL TRAINING FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO MEET THE WORK
FORCE THE MAN.
WITH OVER TWELVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN EDUCATION AND
CAREER DEVELOPMENT THIS CALL
MANAGEMENT COUNSELING MRS GO IS
A PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE NEED
THE INLAND EMPIRE TO DRIVE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
THREE HI RODRIGUEZ ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER SANTIAGO.
PATTY RODRIGUEZ IS NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED ON AIR RADIO
PERSONALITY KEYNOTE SPEAKER AND
ENTREPRENEUR SHE IS THE CO
FOUNDER OF THE BILINGUAL
CHILDREN'S BOOK PUBLISHING
COMPANY LITTLE LIBRES.
WHICH NOW FIRST MULTIPLE
BESTSELLING TITLES ON AMAZON
INTERNET RETAILERS.
PATTY CAME UP WITH IDEA AFTER
BEING UNABLE TO SHE COULD ENJOY
READING HER BABY.
BORN IN LOS ANGELES MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND RAISED IN
SOUTH EAST LOS ANGELES SHE'S
BECOME A ROLE MODEL IN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY AND GIVEN A
VOICE OF HOPE TO THE YOUTH
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
FOUR RABBI LISA EDWARDS ESCORTED
BY PHONE NUMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
RABBI LISA EDWARDS PHD HAS BEEN
A JEWISH LESBIAN ACTIVIST AND
SPIRITUAL LEADER FOR BEDTIME HOW
TO STEAM HOUSE OF NEW LIFE THE
WORLD'S FIRST SYNAGOGUE FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO BY LGBT
PEOPLE.
SERVING SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR RABBI
EDWARDS IS A SOUGHT AFTER
SPEAKER TEACHER WRITER OR
SCHOLAR CLERGY PERSON AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE RIGHTS AND
SPIRITUAL NEEDS OF LGBT PEOPLE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
FIVE ANY SIDE ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER CHEN.
ANY SIZE THE CO FOUNDER OF LAKE
AVENUE THE WOMEN'S CLOTHING
BRAND RECOGNIZED WORLDWIDE FOR
INNOVATIVE HALLOWEEN COSTUMES
FASHION WAYS THREE AND INTIMATE
APPAREL.
CHAMPION OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN
THE WORKPLACE AND A DEDICATED
MENTOR SHE HOPES TO INSPIRE
OTHER YOUNG WOMAN TO TAKE ON
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN BUSINESS
[inaudible]
WHAT?
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY SIX
BEACH IS EASY IT'S ALL AS A
SCORE BY FAMILY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA.
INSPIRED BY HER PARENTS FEATURES
EVEN SALAS COACHELLA VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
COORDINATOR OF EXPANDING
LEARNING AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
HAS DECADE OVER TWENTY YEARS
ADVOCATING FOR YOUTH SERVICES IN
AREAS OF EDUCATION MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
HER EXPERIENCE DEDICATION OF
VOLUNTEERISM ARE WELL
DISTINGUISHED IN THE FIFTY SIX
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
pESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER
CALDERON.
THE EXCAVATOR CURRENTLY SERVES
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
CENSUS PROGRAM AT THE LA --
EDUCATIONAL FUND WHERE SHE IS
LEADING NATIONAL AT FIRST.
MISS ESCOVEDO HAS OVER TWELVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN LEADING
AND ORGANIZING SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGNS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
EIGHT ZERO MARA --
HANIEL CORP ANYA ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA C.
MARKER PENA HAS SPENT THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS OF HER LIFE WORKING
IN VOLUNTEERING IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR.
ADVOCATING FOR IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE RIGHTS AS WELL AS RACIAL
JUSTICE SHE IS CURRENTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF CAPACITY BUILDING.
BUT THE GROUNDS WILL FUND WHICH
SUPPORTS GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS LED BY WOMEN OF
COLOR
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT --
FIFTY NINE MERGING HOLLYWOOD
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER%
CARILLO ON THE BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER --
MERGING HOLLYWOOD AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS GRANNY HAS BEEN
POLITICALLY ACTIVE SINCE
REALIZING THE POWER OF FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE FOR THE 99%.
HER ACTIVISM HAS TAKEN HER ALL
ACROSS AMERICA ONE OF HER BEST
HIGHLIGHTS IS PARTICIPATING IN
THE CAMPAIGN TO FLIP NEW MEXICO
FROM RED TO BLUE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT WHILE WORKING TO ELECT
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IRMA'S KNOWING TO BE FEARLESS
WHEN APPROACHING LOCAL AND STATE
LEADERS REGARDING ANY MATTER
CONCERNING FOR LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES AT
EVER IN A BATTLE YOU DEFINITELY
WANT TO BE ON HER SIDE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SIXTY
MARIANNE SHERMAN ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER CERVANTES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES IS PROUD TO HAVE
CHOSEN MERION SHERMAN AS THE
STICK TO THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE MERION HAS
DEDICATED HER TIME ENERGY AND
ATTENTION TO PROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
HER EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP
COMBINED WITH OUR SERVICE TO
OTHERS IS INSPIRATIONAL AND MOST
DESERVING OF THIS ON WILL
RECOGNITION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY ONE
CONTRA RIVERA ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA.
CONTRA RIVERA IS A COMMITTED
ADVOCATE FOR EDUCATION
CONTINUING THE LEGACY OF HER
LATE HUSBAND THOMAS RIVERA.
SHE CONTRIBUTORS SERVICE TO THE
CALIFORNIA.
RIVERSIDE ART MUSEUM AND THE
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
CONSCIOUS TRAVEL TO SIXTY THREE
COUNTRIES ENJOYED BALLROOM
DANCING READING AND PLAYING
TENNIS
.
FROM A SOME HE TO SUNNY BY
ESCORTED BY SOME THE MEMBER
BURKE.
SONNY BLOCK IS A PROUD VENICE
RESIDENTS SINCE THE LATE
NINETIES HER LOVE FOR PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE SHARE THROUGH
OUR AND PHOTOGRAPHY AS CHAIR
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT.
AS A RESULT OF OUR PASSION SONNY
HAS HELPING THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO ENJOY THE ANNUAL
AWARD WINNING VENICE ART CRAWL.
WHICH WILL BE CELEBRATING THEIR
NINETY YEAR AND THE MEDIA VENICE
ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH
.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTY FOUR MARKER AYE
HERNANDEZ IS GROW BY SOME THE
NUMBER GETS IN.
IS THERE N<c.cyan> DOES IS A</c>
GRADUATE OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY
AND EARNED CERTIFICATES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATION FUND.
AND CORAL LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS
SHE SERVED IN LEADERSHIP ROLES
FOR VARIOUS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS LOCATED IN THE
SOUTH BAY AREA.
MR NOW THIS IS BEEN A MEMBER OF
THE WILMINGTON ROTARY CLUB SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND A
CARSON RESIDENT SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AS A
RETIREE SHE CONTINUES TO BE
ACTIVE ON LOCAL BOARDS HIS
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE CULTURAL
SOCIAL AND VOCATIONAL AGENDAS TO
FIRE LOCAL YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
MISTER LANDIS IS ALWAYS
AVAILABLE TO SHARE HER NETWORK
CONTACTS AND EXPERTISE TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF RESIDENTS
WITHIN THE HARBOR COMMUNITIES.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SIXTY FIVE
ALLEN ON ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
ALLEN ON IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FREEH AND COMMUNITY SERVICES A
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED AGENCY
IN ORANGE COUNTY SHE'S COMMITTED
TO ISSUES INVOLVING HEALTHCARE
ACCESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
MENTAL ILLNESS.
SHE HOLDS A JD FROM GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY AND NSW FROM USC
ALLEN IS A DEDICATED WIFE MOTHER
AND COMMUNITY MEMBER
[inaudible]
I GOT.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY SIX
THEIR H. DEAN ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
BORN AND RAISED IN CALIFORNIA DR
SARAH DEAN IS A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TRAIN DENTIST
RECENTLY AS FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT CREASED TO RETIRE TO
DEVOTE MYSELF TO SERVICE.
DR DEAN PROBABLY SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF THE SOUTH COAST
INTERFAITH COUNCIL AS A BRIDGE
BUILDER BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AT
DIFFERENT TRADITIONS
--
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY
EIGHT MERRY AS DISCOUNTING
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI.
YES THIS COUNTY GRADUATED FROM
THE UNIVERSITY WASHINGTON WITH A
BA DEGREE IN BUSINESS AND
PRESIDING IN MANAGEMENT FINANCE
AND MARKETING.
SHE IS PRESIDENT OF SPECTRUM
SPECIALTIES AND AWARDS A WOMAN
HUGS BUSINESS SHE IS A FOUNDING
MEMBER AND THE CEO OF THE LAKE
FOREST CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
SHE SUPPORTS SEVERAL CHARITIES
IN HER COMMUNITY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY THE SEVENTY
VANDERLANDE BOMB ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
MANDOLIN FONG IS A PRESIDENT'S
SCHOLAR IN HER SOPHOMORE YEAR AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
LONG BEACH WHERE SHE STUDYING
POLITICAL SCIENCE SEC WILL BE
SHE'S INVOLVED IN THE HONORS
PROGRAM AND THE CAMBODIAN
STUDENT SOCIETY.
PRIOR TO BEGINNING HER COLLEGE
CAREER SHE IS PART OF SHE HOPES
TO PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO ADDICT EDUCATE
VOTERS ABOUT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S BUILDING CENTERS AND IS
LEARNING AMERICAN SHIRT ARE KIM
BUILDING COMMUNITY WILL BE
COUNTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
ONE BETTY MCMILLAN ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER VOEPEL.
BETTY HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF THE LAKE SIDE COMMUNITY SINCE
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES SHE IS
PRESIDENT OF THE LAKESIDE
HISTORICAL SOCIETY INCOME CO
FOUNDER AND CHAIR OF THE MAIN
AVENUE REVITALIZATION
ASSOCIATION.
SHE THEN PROBABLY RECOGNIZED BY
THE LAKESIDE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE SAVER HERITAGE
ORGANIZATION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
TWO DOCTOR FONG TRYING HOW
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEDE.
DOCTOR FONG TRYING HOW AND HER
FAMILY ARRIVED TO THE UNITED
STATES FROM VIETNAM IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX SHE GRADUATED FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE AND RECEIVE HER DOCTOR
PHARMACY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SHE'S COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER THE
LAMP THE BEST AND DEDICATED
MOTHER AND VOWS OF DOCTOR DO SO
.
FROM SENATE-DISTRICT SEVENTY
FOUR BETTER FROM A SCHOOL BASED
ON THE NUMBER PETRIE-NORRIS A
FORMER EDUCATOR IRVINE MAYOR AND
COMMUNITY LEADER BET COM IS A
LEADING ADVOCATE FOR CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT REGIONAL
COLLABORATION AND COALITION
BUILDING AN ORANGE COUNTY.
DURING HER FIRST TERM AS MAYOR
IRVINE WAS NAMED THE SAFEST BIG
CITY IN AMERICA A DISTINCTION
THAT CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER BETTER
CONSTRUED TENSION Là QUALITY OF
LIFE PRIORITIES AND MENTOR
COUNTLESS WOMEN IN LOCAL
POLITICS A CHIU COMMUNITY
BUILDER FIFTH COLUMN IS A MENTOR
AN ADVOCATE A CIVIC LEADER AND
RESPECTED AND AWARD WINNING
PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
SHE LEADS WITH COURAGE AND
ALWAYS A LANCER VISION WITH HER
VALUES.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
SIX KARINA CONTRAST ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER FOR BACK.
IN A CONTRAST AS THE FIRST
LATINA TO SERVE ON THE VISTA
CITY COUNCIL AND CURRENTLY
REPRESENTS DISTRICT.
ONE AFTER GRADUATING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
SANTA BARBARA TWENTY ELEVEN
GREEN ENJOYED.
RETURNED TO HER HOMETOWN VISTA
AND START A BUSINESS CALLED
MILLENNIAL FARMER PROVIDING
REGENERATIVE FARMING PRACTICES.
CREATE A PURPOSE SEE SERVED AS A
VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
RECOGNIZED IN OUR COMMUNITY AS A
ON'T FOR NEWER GRASSROOTS
ACTIVISTS AND A LIFELONG
COMMITTEE ADVOCATE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
SEVEN DEBBIE KIRK ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBERS AND SALAS ON THE
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
AS A RESIDENT OF RANCHO BERNARDO
DEMOCRATS NOT ONLY HOLDS THE
TITLE OF PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
BUSINESS SERVICES INTERNATIONAL
SHE IS ALSO A DEDICATED TWENTY
SERVICE VOLUNTEER WITH THE
RANCHO BERNARDO COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION.
AND HOUSE OFF THE VOLUNTEERS
PROGRAM WHAT CHRIS HEIGHT H.
AWAY AND MASTER COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION BERNARDO HEIGHTS.
AMONG MANY OTHER RECOGNITIONS
DEBBIE IS A TWENTY NINETEEN AT
DUCK DE AND TO THE RANCHO
BERNARDO HALL OF FAME FOR HER
MANY YEARS OF LEADERSHIP AND
SERVICE AND EVERY TIME SHE
ENJOYS BAKING GOLFING AND SCUBA
DIVING.
ALONG WITH SINGING AND
PERFORMING WITH LOCAL GROUPS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
EIGHT PROJECT BROWNING ESCORTED
BY SONY MEMBER GLORIA.
PROJECT FROWNING AS PRESIDENT OF
UNITE HERE LOCAL THIRTY
REPRESENTING OVER SIX THOUSAND
WORKERS IN SAN DIEGO'S HOTEL AND
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRIES.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SHE
SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATED AND TO A
THIRTY FIVE DAY STRIKE AT WESTIN
GASLAMP.
RESULTING IN IMPROVED PAY AND
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR HOTEL
WORKERS WHO ARE VITAL TO SAN
DIEGO'S ECONOMY
[inaudible] ONE
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
NINE DIANNE MáS ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER WEBER.
ST MáS IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
ADVOCATE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
ACTIVIST WORKING TO BUILD AN
ACQUITTAL FOOD SYSTEM IN THE SAN
DIEGO REGION.
THROUGH HER WORK INVOLVEMENT AND
NONPROFIT SHE IS TRANSFORMING
THE POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT USING NEIGHBORHOOD
BASED I RECALL TO COOPERATE.
I STRATEGIES OF RESISTANCE TO
FOOD INSECURITY
--
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTY
NOR OF ARGUS ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS IT'S ALL AS NORA VARGAS
IS VICE PRESIDENT OF COMMUNITY
AND GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
AT THE PACIFIC SOUTHWEST.
SHE SERVES ON SOUTHWESTERN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM BOARD.
THE FIRST LATINA TO DO SO NORTH
PRESENTATION AND MENTORING YOUNG
WOMEN LEADERS
[inaudible]
FROM ASSEMBLY SEVEN IS SEND YOU
TAKE A SALAS.
IT'S GREAT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOVE -- HIS
ANYA IS A REGIONAL COORDINATOR
FOR UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY AND VICE PRESIDENT AT THE
CENTRAL COAST LABOR COUNCIL.
AT THIRTEEN YEAR UNION ORGANIZER
SHE'S A STRONG VOICE FOR LABOR
WORKS NONSTOP TO NEGOTIATE
BETTER WAGES AND BENEFITS FOR
HOME CARE PROVIDERS.
WORKFORCE COMPOSED MOSTLY OF
WOMEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY TO SEE HAYES
ESCORTED BY SOME REMEMBER
WALDRON.
JUANITA HATE IS A CAREER PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE RELATIONS AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING HAS BEEN
REWARDING BUT NOTHING HAS BEEN
MORE FULFILLING THAN THE WORK
SHE HAS DONE FOR HER COMMUNITY.
SHE DEVOTED TIME TO COMMUNITY
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING ON BOARDS AND VOLUNTEER
WORK LISTEN RECOGNIZED
NATIONALLY FOR HER SERVICES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY
THREE OF ON THE CELL IT'S GREAT
BY SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON.
A BOMB IS STILL IS A THIRTY TWO
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF SOUTH
GATE FOR SHE AND HER HUSBAND
RATE THEIR TWO CHILDREN.
SHE HAS DEDICATED MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS OF SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY AS A PARENT VOLUNTEER.
SHE'S A FOUNDING MEMBER AND
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF PADRES YOU.
APPARENT ADVOCACY GROUP FORMED
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO
ADVOCATE FOR NEW SCHOOLS IN
SOUTH GATE
.
THE FOLLOWING HONOREES WERE
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY REGION
AGAIN FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
ELEVEN DOCTOR CHRISTINE BOSSI
FORD FROM AND SOME.
KAREN TO THE FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
FORTY TWO ABLE J. BY DEL FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
SIXTY SEVEN JENNY REELS FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SIXTY NINE
AND MICHELLE HERRINGTON FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
SEVENTY THREE WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF WOMEN WE ARE PRIVILEGED
AS TO STATE TO HAVE ALL OF YOU
HERE SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SRVICE TO OUR GREAT STATE AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING A PART OF
OUR PROGRAM.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
PLEASE REMAIN SEATED AS WE
CONTINUE SESSION --
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL GUEST IN
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY AND I WILL
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR THAT INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER --
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS TODAY I'M VERY HONORED
TO INTRODUCE A FRIEND AND A
MENTOR APPLYING.
THE SECRETARY NORM MINETA ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MISTER MINETA HAS MOST RECENTLY
SERVE IN THE PRESIDENT GEORGE
BUSH'S CABINET AS U. S.
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION.
FROM 200-012-2000 SIX AND
COORDINATED THE ACTION DURING
THE NINE ELEVEN ATTACK.
PRIOR TO THAT HE WAS PRESIDENT
BILL CAN CLINTON'S SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE MAKING HIM THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN. TO HOLD A
POSITION IN THE PRESENT DAY
IMMIGRANT PARENTS SECRETARY
MINETA WAS BORN IN SAN JOSE.
THAT HIS FAMILY WAS ENDING
INTERNMENT CAMP DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO MR MEN THAT HAS STARTED HIS
POLITICAL CAREER IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN WHEN HE WAS
APPOINTED TO SOUTH OF THE CITY
COUNCIL AND WENT ON TO READ THE
MAYOR OF SAN JOSE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE HE LEFT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND WAS ELECTED
TO THE US HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IN NINETEEN SO.
FOUR AS SERVICE FOR TWENTY YEARS
IN CONGRESS UNTIL HE JOINED
PRESIDENT CLINTON'S CABINET AND
THEM PRESIDENT BUSH'S CABINET.
SELLS A CITY COUNCIL AND MAYOR
NAME SAN JOSE INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT AFTER MISTER MINETA INTO
SALT. ONE TO COMMEMORATE HIS
POSITIVE CHANGES AND IMPACT THAT
HE BROUGHT TO THIS IS THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE AND TO OUR NATION.
MADAM SPEAKER THE M. MEMBERS
PLEASE HELP ME RECOGNIZE.
SECRETARY.
NORM MINETA AND HIS WIFE DANNY
TO THE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU AND
WELCOME MR MONETTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY THE CHAMBERS
TODAY IS OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON BIRTHDAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING
SPEAKER RENDON A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THEY SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH FIFTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH
SIXTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTH WE HAVE
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAINS THE MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH SEVENTH AT NINE AM.
A QUORUM CALLS LIFTED